[Musique]
bonjour je suis à l'excès barre et
sophrologue et coach de vie ces méthodes
vous êtes vraiment à vous sentir mieux
au quotidien améliorer votre qualité de
vie
et aujourd'hui je vous propose une
nouvelle séance allons-y
vous prenez un manche à balai chien vous
retirez la brosse et on va faire des
squats
vous mettez bien opposition les pieds de
largeur du bassin le dos droit le ventre
gainey et vous allez faire comme si vous
alliez vous asseoir sur une chaise en
arrière en maintenant bien les genoux
dans l'alignement des orteils et vous
montez vos bras à l'horizontale et vous
soufflez en remontant et en remontant
n'oubliez surtout pas de bien contracté
lèche les cuisses et les fessiers donc
l'idéal c'est d'en faire une dizaine à
votre rythme
le mieux sinon vous mettez de la musique
de fond pour vous entraîner un petit peu
au fur et à mesure des séances vous
progressez et vous arrivez en faire
beaucoup plus
prenez deux bouteilles d'eau au fond et
on va travailler les bras les 1700
vraiment cette partie là vous collez les
coudes
le long de votre corps et vous allez
remonter tranquillement
voilà en soufflant à chaque fois le
principe de cette séance et de tonifier
vos bradley musclé muscler vos biceps et
au fur et à mesure des séances vous
allez les affiner si vous multipliez le
nombre de répétitions
donc faites en une trentaine au départ
et au fur et à mesure de votre
progression vous pouvez en faire plus
alors j'espère que cette séance vous a
plu et petit bonus le score va vous
aider à libérer deux hormones
l'endorphine qui est l'hormone du
antistress du bien-être et la dopamine
qui est l'hormone du plaisir du bonheur
le sport vous aide à vous sentir mieux
dans votre corps à être plus tonique
plus gainey est également donc mieux
dans votre tête
vraiment la sérénité le bien-être je
vous dis à bientôt sur la chaîne